So, we started out lesson one using a
lot of different functions, and we built two main
projects. In the first one, we helped our
friends take a break and in the second one
we sent a secret message to our loved
ones. Then we came across a scenario, while building
a movie website, where using functions didn't quite present
a very elegant solution. That solution requires something new.
And that new idea, in programming, is called classes,
and here in lesson two, we will spend a
lot of time, and build a lot of different
examples, showcasing the power of using classes. Now, we will
return to our movie database example in lesson three.
But here, in lesson two, we will start out with
ideas and examples that are the easiest for me
to explain the power of classes to you. Let's begin.